foreign  coming to you with sad news today I've  just read that Bobby Coltrane who  famously played Ruby's Hagrid has passed  away at the age of 72. apparently  Coltrane had been fighting poor health  for the last couple of years and finally  died in hospital near his home in  Scotland the last time Coltrane appeared  on camera was this year during the 20th  Harry Potter anniversary special  returned to Hogwarts I think I can speak  for everyone when I say that Ruby's  Hagrid was one of the best parts of my  childhood and an absolute Staple in  Harry Potter Robbie Coltrane was perfect  for the role and I couldn't have  imagined anyone else playing The Lovable  half giant it's tough getting older and  seeing our childhood Heroes passing away  but Coltrane once said in an interview  himself that Hagrid would live forever